whose luck hey goose goosey look here
Hey
oh my god to become a children's
photographer Mother's Day is this
weekend by dog good night with the same
size head
it is Mother's Day weekend this weekend
you didn't know now you know and I
thought I would give you a very very
last minute gift guide here are some
super last-minute super cheap gifts that
you can give to your mom this Mother's
Day a problem roses are red violets are
blue sugar is sweet how do I get dental
insurance make her crap do you see the
symbolism this is me hanging by a thread
in this shadow box that's you but no
wait that one right oh my gift card
having Mother's Day yes I know that you
got me this for Christmas I was testing
you to see how old your brain is I love
you but if none of those things work
don't worry I have you covered I've
teamed up with YouTube and tumblr and I
have created a Mother's Day [ __ ]
generator or gift generator if you are a
person that feels very adamantly about
either pronunciation cool use of time
and energy so in honor of my own mother
who has inspired me in so many ways and
supported me in so many ways and
provided so many great moments and vlogs
yeah
the interesting thing about green bean
casserole guess what it never happens
it's a resolution we know and dishwasher
open by itself
I mean cold
well that is she said that's what she
said have you ever heard that phrase is
it oh that's okay it's old it's
basically like a way to talk about sex
don't get makeup on my shirt probably
they don't know this is my mother
hey nice you might get my awkward hands
now
I've teamed up with YouTube to create
things mom gifs
for Mother's Day that's right you can go
to my tumblr page grace Helbig tumblr
comm all weekend long to create Mother's
Day gifs look every time that there is
any family related holiday or any
holiday in general I'm on Instagram I
see all the photos everyone posts I feel
so in an attempt to take the photos of
you and your mom that you know you're
gonna post on mother's day more
interesting we have created a hashtag
thanks mom ship generator on grace
helbig depth tumbler calm there's an
assortment of designs and things to say
to your mom and gifs and templates and
all kinds of cool stuff that you can use
to post on Mother's Day to send that
extra special thank you to your mom
hashtag thanks mom and you know it's
good because one-on-one Oh grace
helbig's mom approve I approve
make sure that you check out grace hope
we got tumblr.com all again long to
create your thanks mom chip or photo and
make sure to hashtag it so I can find it
and see it and judge it and love it like
a real mom I don't know this is as close
as you will get to a granddaughter and
very sorry but look her head is the size
of a human when I hold you like this
thing you look like a giant toddler and
you have the disposition of an elderly
man